the opening scene features a
full-fledged lawyer Yung who is trying
to defend her father for a crime he did
not commit it turns out that her father
was falsely accused of sexual assaults
and murder of a little girl in the court
trial Yung claims that the prosecutor is
making false claims since she is a
witness to the whole incident later
while leaving the prison Court after a
successful trial Yung notices a balloon
entangled in barbed wire that [__] would
definitely have popped but it's a nice
poetic image I guess the scene then Cuts
back to the Year 1997 where a 6-year-old
Yung and her father y gu are staring at
a store window they are admiring a
Sailor Moon backpack Yu promises to buy
his daughter the backpack as soon as he
gets paid from work just then they
notice a police commissioner purchasing
that bag for his daughter yangu rushes
in to grab the backpack but he is
assaulted by the officer and kicked out
of the store and Tuxedo Mask is not
there to save them after the incident
the two return home without the bag bag
slightly battered but in High Spirits
Yung being a kind and smart child
understands the situation and doesn't
feel sad despite not getting the bag
even though she is very young she takes
care of her father who has a
developmental disability and may well
have wanted that backpack for himself
the following day yangu gets paid at
work while counting the money he is
approached by the earlier police
commissioner's daughter who offers to
guide him to another store that sells
the same backpack but in an unfortunate
accident the little girl slips on the
Market's icy pavement and a brick drops
on her head resulting in her death in a
desperate that's crazy man in a
desperate bid to revive the little girl
yangu proceeds to perform CPR however a
female bystander misunderstands him and
reports him for assaulting and killing
the girl following this Yu is
apprehended and taken to the police
station due to his mental illness he
doesn't understand that he is arrested
so he tries to leave citing that his
daughter is alone at home however this
only results in him getting beaten by
the police officers who keep him in
custody until the next day in the
morning the police make false comments
on his actions alleging that he sought
revenge on the commissioner by
assaulting his daughter to add to his
predicament he is forced to make a false
reenactment in exchange for meeting his
daughter in the meantime Yung who gets
worried for her father sets off to find
him not long after she notices a crowd
surrounding the crime scene and soon
discovers her father in handcuffs scared
the little girl rushes to him but she is
quickly held back by the officers that's
my uncle Peter in the aftermath of this
event Yu is sent to prison where the
warden beats him up for committing such
a crime he is then detained in cell
number seven along with five other
inmates they also beat him up for his
falsely accused crime despite all this
the innocent Yu keeps on thinking about
his daughter during working hours the
inmates are tasked to make soccer balls
one of Yango's cellmates named Yang ho
who is considered the leader uses these
balls as an alibi to smuggle things by
Distributing these smuggled products the
leader and his gang establish their Turf
within the prison however this has also
earned them several enemies one day the
rival gang leader tries to stab yho from
behind but Yong go who notices this
intervenes just in time and saves him
his actions impress the leader deeply
later on yango offers to help him in any
way he can to return the favor in
response yongo expresses his wish to see
his daughter Yeung as a result the
little girl is brought into the prison
along with a team of choir who were
there for a performance after waiting
for the right time the girl is abducted
and smuggled inside cell number seven to
meet her father this is probably not how
Yu wanted things to happen his soon as
yungu meets her he Embraces her
emotionally he apologizes for leaving
her and explains that he is being
detained however their reunion is cut
short because the church event is
disbanded the fellow inmates then
hurriedly try to smuggle her out but
they are too late the church's bus has
already departed as a result they have
no choice but to keep the girl inside
the cell with them one of the cellmates
freaks out thinking about the
consequences if they get caught so he
opts to alert the guards however he
can't do so when he looks at yong's
crying face upon living with them the
fellow cellmates realize that yangu
can't be an as salent since he loves his
daughter so much a couple of days passed
by and the cell room now looks more like
Yeung playground rather than a prison
cell since they don't know Yung is in
there this will definitely look bad to
the guards for yangu the inmates
eventually get along with her and warm
up to her due to her brightness one
night the prison Warden goes through the
pictures from the choir event and
discovers that one of the performing
Girls is missing realizing that the girl
has been smuggled inside he orders an
immediate prison wide inspection shortly
after yiang is found and is immediately
sent to the orphanage while yongo is
confined in a solitary cell the same
night a fire breaks out from an
attempted arson as a prisoner protests
against allowing a little girl inside
the prison amidst of the chaos all
prisoners are sent to the Courtyard
while the warden breaks into the cell to
apprehend the protester however the Fire
gets bigger and both Warden and the
protester are trapped inside upon
witnessing this yongo courageously jumps
into the Flames to rescue them
disregarding potential consequences the
scene then cuts to the hospital where
the warden wakes up to learn that he is
saved by yangu this makes him realize
that the man's crime report was
fabricated and that he can't commit such
a heinous act on the other hand Yung
resumes her school after classes her
teacher asks about why she was absent
but Yung simply desires to meet her
father following this she takes her
teacher to prison leaving her in shock
once there the father and daughter are
Overjoyed to see each other again seeing
the love between the two of them the
teacher doesn't bother them and
participates in their conversation a
instead however their happiness is
shortlived as the visit time Runs Out
causing them to be separated the warden
sees yangong gu's love towards his
daughter for the first time and is more
convinced about his suspicion this only
makes him recall his memories about his
only son who is killed by an inmate
after the separation Yung Grieves so
much that she doesn't eat anything and
ultimately ends up in the hospital the
prison Warden visits her to check her
well-being during this the little girl
requests to arrest her and take her to
her father's cell touched by this the
warden allows her to visit her father
every day after school in addition he
reviews Yu's Crime files and discovers
that his sworn statement is falsified
after seeing the Injustice that yongo is
facing the warden vows to prove his
innocence he then goes to the
commissioner and requests for
reinvestigation of Yu's case unbeknown
to the fact that it was the commissioner
who set him up meanwhile within the
prison the inmates from s number seven
enjoy their time with Yeung the little
girl teaches the leader how to read and
write his weakness that nobody knew
about but now they do and they laugh at
him one day Yung borrows a cell phone
from one of her classmates and brings it
inside the prison she hands it to an
inmate allowing him to call his wife and
his newborn baby girl it's great you s
you break some laws for me too little
girl let's go bring me a shank you s
yeah as the days pass by they all form a
special bond with yeang and start living
like like a family a family where more
than 50 of her uncles have killed people
apart from all this they also learned
that Yu's final trial date is
approaching in response the inmates
pledged to train him for success in the
trial because they've all clearly
experienced that so that he can return
to his happy life with his daughter for
this they first ask yongo to explain the
incident in detail they also go through
several scenarios in order to get the
picture of the incident after a few days
they finally conclude that the
commissioner's girl actually s slipped
on a frozen puddle while falling the
girl grabbed a plastic wrap that caused
a brick to fall in her head and kill her
this is I'm even starting to doubt this
story the inmates also learned that
yangu was blackmailed into signing a
falsified report due to which he ended
up here having unraveled the truth yongo
is trained on how to answer potential
prosecution questions even though it's
hard due to his mental illness they are
still confident that he will win because
he has been mistreated the inmates make
a note about all the possible question
questions along with their answers which
yongo studies day and night Additionally
the cellmates organize a petition from
fellow prisoners to attend Yu's trial in
a show of support amidst the
preparations a public lawyer comes to
meet yongo the lawyer says that he must
plead guilty to save his daughter
asserting that the commissioner will
hurt Yeung if he wins the trial the
lawyer also abandons the prisoners
petition saying it won't help because
they've all killed people in the next
scene the long anticipated at trial day
arrives and yongo is brought to court
for his final verdict in the waiting
room the commissioner beats him in a fit
of rage threatening to kill his daughter
if he doesn't confess a while later the
trial begins and Yu who is very worried
for his daughter sacrifices himself by
pleading guilty to the accusations the
prison Warden tries to convince the
judge that Yu is mentally intimidated
but he is ultimately sentenced to death
the execution date is scheduled for
December 23rd which happens to fall on
you s's birthday back in the prison the
inmates feel sorry for yungu so they
decide to take matters into their own
hands they devise a plan to build a hot
air balloon to facilitate his Escape
they dedicate their days and nights to
this project driven by the motivation to
free an innocent man from the clutches
of Injustice and to do it like Willie
[__] Wonka too they also request all
of the other prisoners and yung's
teachers help in order to commence the
plan a few days later the prison
organizes a program in which Ye Sung a
along with some other children perform a
choir at the end of the performance Yung
takes her father's hand and invites him
to the yard with other prisoners joining
to create the illusion that the event is
ongoing seizing the moment the inmates
send Yu and yiang on the balloon and
release the Rope they're dead for sure
as they fly away the guards become aware
of their escape attempt but the
prisoners stop them from chasing the
balloon what if they snipe it however
the balloon's Rope is caught by barbed
wire causing their plan to fail now with
nowhere to go the father and the
daughter used this moment to savor the
Setting Sun together on December 23rd
yangu and the cellmates celebrate yung's
birthday before he is taken for
execution they surprise the little girl
with a birthday cake and multiple gifts
great now she'll never be able to look
at a cake again yangu finally presents
her with the Sailor Moon backpack which
they have been thinking of buying for a
long time Overjoyed with the present the
little girl thanks him for being her
father as the two embrace the rest of
the fellow inmates being aware of yo
fate are unable to hold their tears back
despite this they don't utter a single
word in front of the little girl they
simply pretend that her father is being
transferred to another facility and tell
her to stay strong shortly afterwards
the prison guards arve to take Yu for
execution before leaving he thanks all
of his fellow cellmates for their care
and support the inmates are clearly
saddened but they are helping less as
yongo walks past the hall with his
daughter the other prisoners also share
in the sorrow when the moment of
Separation comes Yu tries hard to hold
his tears back he hugs Yung for the last
time before heading to his execution
while walking away he hears his
daughter's voice and rushes back to
embrace her he pleads for help because
he doesn't want to be separated from his
daughter however it's too late now and
even the warden seems powerless poor
yangu is eventually executed Ed for a
crime he did not commit 16 years later
Yung who is now a lawyer appeals for her
father's case who is still considered to
be a criminal with the prison Warden and
the room seven inmates support she is
finally able to prove his innocence the
judge exonerates yongo by overturning
the previous verdict and also orders a
reinvestigation into the little girl's
death bringing immense Joy to the former
inmates the warden and a tearful Yeung
the scene then returns back to the
beginning of the film where Yung has a
vision of yangu and her younger self on
the hot air balloon waving goodbye the
movie ends as she tearfully bids goodbye
to her father as the balloon flies
away [__] subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching